[Music]
this is
so cool our neighbor
donated some pallets
that we are going to use to make our own
compost we're going to be using
greens live foods that we don't use
you put it in one side of the container
and it will compost to make your own
dirt and soil for our garden
it's gonna be amazing guys
look how cute she is got little
homestead
daughters
we all just work as a team look at my
other cutie
oh my gosh we're totally filming each
other
do we want to just carry that one how
many are there okay
oh there's two more oh
but holy heck i need to make sure
i'm not stepping in fire ant
hills seriously i do not need that
if y'all have not had experience with
one two or three little tiny fire ants
it's horrible getting stung by a bee is
bad but
holy spiritual buckets
so this is where we're going to make the
compost at
you can never have too much fun when
you're on your homestead
literally every day is fun day
even when it doesn't feel fun i'm still
making fun
beanta is in the round pen the donkeys
have
chewed it by the way right there hi
binta
you want out so miss haley was
using these bags to help with her
training of desensitizing her
because she's very scared of the bags
and the sound of a bag so we had her in
this training pen
to gently get her desensitized
i'll probably do a video on that someday
but
right now we're working on several other
things aren't we being tough
all right so what is this called a less
pitchfork this is a pitchfork and what
are you going to use it for
i bought you this pitchfork it was 33
at russell's feed and
you really really wanted it what's it
for oh well
i'm using it to
flip my compost so we're going to flip
our compost
with the pitchfork oh what do we have in
here already
is that hey um yeah grass popping
sleeves horse manures okay
grass clippings leaves horse manure and
then
were we gonna do like any i guess
leftover lettuce maybe
from the bunnies and the guinea pigs
oh the watermelon rinds oh my gosh
the ones that the chickens ate yeah it's
pretty hard is it really gonna
is that really gonna mush up into
anything
yeah the bacteria will just attack it
that's pretty crazy
you know thank goodness i don't have to
throw away my watermelon rinds
anymore in the trash oh we can do
cardboard
and this is all okay so when do you know
that you're going to now transfer it to
this side
of the compost well this is a two-step
one so basically that one would be for
the finished compost like once it's like
dirt looking you put it in there so you
can use it
okay um there's also like a three style
one where you flip it and then flip it
back into there
so yeah so where's the dirt is it gonna
be on the bottom or the top
yeah it's gonna decompose at the bottom
and then work its way up
why i don't know i think it's a mix i
know see we're homesteaders
in the learning process yeah so that's
what i love about this it's all hands-on
people don't just magically know the
stuff you start
and we're learning and then
this is going to be passed down to
generations
of carols and wonderful texan
son-in-laws manly
husbands that my daughters are going to
find good men
and they're going to know how to do this
stuff too
someday my grand kitties
they're going to know this like the back
of their hand and it's going to be all
because we had to start
fresh on our own learn it all ourselves
with our neighbors our family my
mother-in-law
she has such wisdom my father-in-law has
such wisdom
my dad has a lot of uh experience with
gardening so he gives us tips too
hi pablo i know she's a bully
she took all the hay look he's in line
you know what i'm gonna get your own hay
yep
[Music]
here is an update on our compost
that we have been working on
as you can see we have
expanded it isn't this so cool
our good neighbors brought some over to
us they donated these cute
blue ones nice texas colors some red
ones
so we're expanding so we can have more
options of
separating like this is the cardboard
and the horse manure that's going to be
starting one
once it starts then she will move it
over
to have the dirt on this side that we
can use
by next spring we're hoping this one
right here
she's got more of pine shavings
just dirt mulch from the chicken coop
some weeds and such and she will move it
over to this section
you have to keep it moist for this
compost
to develop and then she's planning on
making another one right here
where we can do more of fruits and
vegetables
the rinds of the watermelon things like
that
that you can use anything really for the
compost you just can't use
any meat any dairy any animal products
other than manure because you want it to
be a natural source where it's going to
develop into a dirt that you can then
use
for your garden boxes you know many
different things that you can use the
compost for
you can compost veggie cuttings fruit
peels
eggshells the egg cartons
coffee grounds yard trimmings cardboard
junk mail paper wood shavings
tons of stuff thanks so much for
watching guys
as you can see we have a new horse
round pen that we made in previous
videos we had just a plain orange one
we did have to replace it because of our
naughty donkeys they like to play with
it but it's good for our horse
she's already trained i will have an
upcoming video
short video showing how we redid the
round pen
thanks so much for watching again don't
forget to like this video i hope it
helped you
gave you some ideas on making your own
compost
in your backyard in your homestead it's
really beneficial to be able to have
than your own dirt for the upcoming
gardening season
dirt is expensive and you have to figure
out how to haul it to your house and all
that good stuff
don't forget to comment push the
notification bell it's going to
send you either an email or a
notification on your phone if you have
the youtube app
telling you that we have just put out a
new video
[Music]
hey
you